in Canada hockey is like a religion hockey
was the only focus the only thing I wanted
to do there are no holes in Alexander D's
game people truly belied that Alex was the
next coming the first pick alexand they were
expecting him to be some kind of Savior a lot
of good athletes have the ability not to get
distracted Alex did not have the ability not
to get distracted it goes so quick that becomes
a blur this was the worst team in hockey Alex
became the scapegoat when he got too hard for
him you look at away this is your social life
a bit of a distraction he's never going to
meet the fans expectations the knock on Alex
was that he didn't love the game enough to
ever be the best that he could be I never
recaptured The Edge I had and when you lose
that edge you're done maybe there's more to
it